All right Ralph, if you would please introduce yourself
if your name and today's date in our location.
Okay, Ralph Coleman, also Ralph Coleman, Jr., dates
July 8th, and we're in my long time,
residents in East Moreland neighborhood, Portland,
and when you're discussed, OEC and where you stayed,
so on.
Yes, talk about your father and your association
with the University of Macquaras as well.
So, let's start with your dad.
Can you give us a little background on his upbringing?
Where he was born and where he was raised?
Okay, sure.
He was born and raised in Canby,
which is a suburb of Portland, South,
and basically a farming community.
He had a small family, he had a younger brother,
a two-year younger brother.
His father, P.L., or Philip Coleman,
had come west from Ohio and probably
before the turn of the century.
And it was an educator and was super into the schools
there and can't be, that's where my dad grew up
when to can be high school and graduated.
I think they're very first graduating class in 1914,
my during the state, then OEC.
And it's not entirely clear what year has he was born?
Well, it's pretty clear it's 1896.
There's an affidavit from his aunt, who raised him
and stayed in the birth day and so on.
But back in 1896, there were no birth certificates.
So the record's either kept in a family Bible
or written down someplace.
But he turned up a 1900 census,
somehow it's having been born in 1895.
So he could use that if he wanted to be a year older.
He used the 1895 date if he wanted to be a year younger
to reduce 1896.
And his mother died when he was about four or five years old.
And there were the family that my grandfather had married
into, sort of took the boys on and raised them.
This is primary, primary character,
who was his aunt, Ella, and Kathy.
OK, it sounds like athletics were important to him
from early age.
Well, I would seem so that in that era,
they probably, I don't know if they played football or anything
like that, but yes, they had baseball team.
I have a picture in these archives,
a few in his uniform, and then with his team.
And played baseball for the mobile team.
He's arm or shoulder or something.
And it was not expected to ever play baseball.
Yeah, so he made the decision to work in agricultural college
in 1914.
Do you know why he made that decision?
I don't.
I think they were talked about it.
It's probably closer than the U of O.
Yeah, that decision to go to college, period.
The decision to go.
I don't know if that's interesting.
His brother never went.
And his dad had been to college, but it wasn't a tradition.
The family, none of the, he's a standard family
in the can be area.
I don't think it ever made a college.
So I don't know what motivated me to do this,
just to smart, ambitious kid.
People liked him.
He took off.
He made it in dairy health injury.
Major in dairy health has been really good.
Well, he grew up in the farm community.
And on the farm.
So this was a natural thing for him.
And there's pictures of him on campus.
He's had, judging a cow.
There's nothing like that, you know.
So he came out with a degree in dairy health injury in 1918.
And it was immediately drafted into the Army in World War I.
And went to Fort Lewis.
Camp Lewis, the time for Lewis.
Infantry, basic, you know, of the meat grinder route.
The war was climaxing in 1918.
And the big offensive were going on.
So he needed a lot of people.
And he was infantry, basic, applied for OCS.
Officers, candidate school.
We sent him to that.
And that prolonged his stay.
Just long enough for the war to end before they left.
But he was commissioned to second Lieutenant and the machine got a battalion or something like that.
And Maddie's due avoid the war of the major part of it.
Did he ever talk about his academic experience as a student?
Uh, hey, I don't remember any great, you know, long comments about that.
It was primarily an agricultural school.
He had a technical component to it.
The agriculture was the main thrust.
I don't know.
It's a good question.
I don't know what it didn't hear that much about the coursework.
Well, we normally associate him with baseball.
But it sounds like he perhaps his greater talent was in tracking field.
That's true.
It was.
He would talk about this.
He went or he's the never-run at all when it ever competed in there.
I've been in a race and never did anything.
And somehow got acquainted with some people on the track team and the cross country team.
And he said, come on, run with us.
And he ran him into the ground, basically.
He just is a natural.
And so they said, OK, you're, come out track, you know.
He had developed into quite a respectable distance man.
His best time in the mile was in, is about 4 or 20.
And I think my son was looking up the world's record of the time was about 4, 15 or 14 or something like that.
So this was a very respectable level of achievement.
And there would have been an Olympics in 1918 that he probably was, you know, tried for the American team and probably better pretty good shot at.
Of course, the war caused that to be canceled.
So that was the end of that.
But no track was his major athletic activity in Oregon State.
He was captain of the track team, competed in the long zone and all that sort of thing.
So yeah, that was his first athletic activity.
Did he ever express any regret that he couldn't have tried to be on the Olympic team?
Well, maybe in passing.
But, you know, that's the way it goes.
We all have good or should have wouldn't have, you know.
We only played baseball for one year at Oregon 8 OEC.
Yes, I think that's correct.
He was playing.
He told me he was playing in a rural baseball.
You know, the varsity in the rural.
And I don't feel good.
You know, injured shoulder apparently had healed up in the intervening years.
And coach saw him play or heard about him said, you know, going out and take.
So he faced some games for them in a senior year and was pretty effective.
I don't think they played more than 20 games, you know, a season.
And then later on, he, he was good enough to play professionally for three or four summers.
After he got out of college for the Portland Beers, which at the time was a triple A club.
And it, good success, good enough to be looked at by the majors.
And at that time, a team like Portland would own the players outright.
And the major leagues would buy the players from the teams they wanted.
If they wanted them, they would buy them from the team.
That's how the team made 20 of his selling to players in the major.
So he, had it was looked at by Detroit, I think.
They wouldn't have been in Oregon State.
He was on the staff by that time.
I think he turned away from that.
The more I secure position.
It was you then in professional baseball at the time.
The more secure position.
More secure position.
Yeah.
The baseball in those days, you know, pay nothing.
Prears were short, you know, no pensions and nothing.
You just played for a while and then you were going on and that was it.
So he, you know, figured he was pretty well positioned where he was.
Stay on.
He got married.
I think by that time, too.
Tell me about the Ocelito Club.
Oh, I don't know very much about it.
Just heard the name.
But I think that was a, the closest I can think it would
might have been kind of a, an eating club.
You know, they lived there.
I don't know what they call them.
Co-ops might have been a co-op.
And sort of a semi fraternity.
And then that morphed him to the, uh,
Gamma Talk beta.
Uh, well, I think he was still not a graduate when that came about.
And then the Gamma Talk beta, eventually of course,
became double UPSLON in the 1922.
And that was, uh, a big part of his, you know,
association with the rest of you.
Well, through through his living situation,
he encountered a couple, well, a few pretty extraordinary people
that he mentioned his best friends were spec key.
And that was okay.
Well, they were close.
And, uh, spec was, uh, from Salem.
And, uh, was a good athlete to student body president.
And they became good friends.
He was the best man at my entire wedding.
And they were, their family and our family were lifelong friends.
So a lot of each other and spec was always around.
And he became athletic directors.
You know what, uh, doing a state rate close ties.
In fact, his daughter lives in Kraval.
She'd be a good person to contact sometime.
If she'd be willing to, you know, provide the information for him.
Doug McCay, I think he might have been a little older than an idea.
Maybe a year or so.
Of course, he would have become governor and secretary of the interior
and under eyes and honor.
So, uh, any other, um,
recollections of spec key in Doug McCay or stories about your father's association with them?
Well, uh, spec was just a marvelous person.
And, uh, load, fishing and hunting, and just all around.
Good administrator and a good guy.
And they did a lot of fishing and, uh, hunting together.
Every summer, uh, for a number of years, we all go to Nesquen,
it doesn't look any different, you know, today,
and I did that for a couple of weeks.
And we, you know, either ten families from the Oregon State
didn't from Salem in various places.
And that was just, uh, summer holiday.
That was Nesquen.
Somehow, as we stayed in, uh, in the mid 30s,
we're still there looking just exactly like we did back then.
So, there's a lot of interaction, you know, a lot of closeness.
And, uh, in, in the time.
Maybe people still do that, I don't know.
How did, uh, how did Ralph meet his wife?
I don't know.
She was a student at Oregon State, uh, a tri-delt.
Uh, she'd grown up in Colberg, went to the University of Oregon for a while.
Uh, and then transferred to Oregon State, I'm not sure why.
She was about three years younger than I did.
And, uh, I was very, come with young woman.
So there were some pictures of her after a while.
As well.
And, um, so, you know, these, I don't know the details.
They dated and got married in there.
In her parents' house in Eugene.
I think it was.
Later on, they lived very,
firstly lived with us.
We grew up with a lot of part of their lives.
And, uh, very nice, extended family situation.
Did he talk any more about other social activities or more about fraternity life,
in his school years?
Well, he'd tell the usual, hazing stories and things like that.
He didn't sound all that much different from my own experience.
Yeah, four years later.
Uh, but, uh, it was, I think Oregon State was a fun place.
I don't think they took life all that seriously.
Yeah.
But we see in those years that it was an egg school primarily,
with a big military component.
Uh, engineering was certainly in the picture.
But I think it was just mostly, uh, uh, local people.
Local kids went there.
Hmm.
Did he mention his ROTC experience?
Yeah, he thought that was great.
He loved ROTC.
Uh, he was good at it.
Yeah, a lot of kind of a command presence.
And, uh, just resonated with his mentality, I guess.
And, uh, the ROTC, I think, was what got him, uh, in the OCS.
You know, you may have saved his funds.
They're at, uh, at Fort Lewis.
Camp Lewis.
Well, I mentioned that the world or one experience kind of came in one of that.
In 1919, he returned to Corvallus.
All right.
Get out of the military and that fall.
I see more end in November.
I think he got out probably in, uh,
80, uh, later on in the year.
Anyway, he went to, uh, move back to Corvallus.
And it was hired by the Corvallus schools.
And they're intramural.
They're, uh, their PE athletic aspect of it,
coaching and things like that.
And, you know, with no background, whatever, and education.
And I think he did that for a year.
Then was, uh, hired.
Put on the staff and all your state within, uh, physical education department.
And they kind of tasked with, uh, developing digital programs.
And, uh, expanding that into the, uh, the, uh,
those facilities, activities available.
He did that pretty much the rest of his career.
He was head of freshman men zero,
head of men's physical education.
So he,
was in the PE department like in 1919 and was there until 1961.
So you found a home.
Yeah, and realize it pretty extensive these days.
Well, together with, you know,
and a very extensive of those new these days.
And apparently we have a rough goal.
And to thank for one.
Well, he got them started.
He didn't, uh, finish it.
But there was what he, that was his original.
In fact, there's a little side for you, you know, where the tennis courts are and it would be
west of, it would be just north of the football facilities on that was the original Coleman
field. Really? Yeah. It was the inner mural field. I don't know, I don't know, it was
ever formally, you know, just called that. And then when the coaching and then he was there
forever, then that became Coleman field. No, interesting little side there that's kind of fun.
He lived at the Gauntel Beta House during this time. Yes, and I know little about that.
But like I said during the while, he was when he came back after the war, and he re-associated
with the fraternity. In fact, with there. And he didn't, wasn't a college or anything, but he just
moved in. And that's when they signed him this promising, but kind of socially awkward
freshman, minus calling. And my dad wasn't at school, but he was, you know, supposed to look
out for a minus and socializing and, you know, getting going at school. And that's when he reported
the House that he didn't take this guy, he's going to make it every state, never studies.
All he does is reap pole blisters and sleeps a lot. So he totally missed the mark on that one.
Minus was so easy for calling that he didn't have to exert himself at all. And as you know,
he was coaching or teaching undergraduate chemistry, I think, by the time he was a sophomore junior.
So he, and was a good guy, I guess, you know, a popular guy, and one of the guys, and, you know,
think of two-time Nobel Prize winners as one of the guys. Normally, I think he always, I think he always
cherished that relationship, you know, because he was shy and sort of, you know, a misfit,
when you're that smart and that, you know, that level of achievement, I think it's, you do,
I think find yourself kind of on the outside. So to whatever extent, it's true, I think the
Gamotaur Beta is socialized him. And, uh, would you like to meet Spam on that a little bit?
Yeah, absolutely. Okay. I met Linus a few times, and we weren't close friends or anything like that.
But he never forgot to read the state. And, uh, in the Gamotaur Beta,
he just became Delta Upslawn in 1922 national fraternity. And Linus Paulang and my dad and a number
of other people were chartered members. And there's pictures somewhere in the soil of his group, you know.
And, uh, his, uh, in 1966, it would have been the, you know, that was a 40 year,
60, yeah, I was later in that. Well, it's in my documentation or somewhere. They had a, uh,
a reunion or a, uh, anniversary. It might be in the 50th, maybe in the 60th, I don't know, uh,
anniversary with the founding of the fraternity. And, uh, you know, all the alums and the
Borland area and so on were there. And the roundup was many of the charter members, as they could find.
And there were about either 10 of them, something like that. And Linus is one and my dad was one.
And each one of them took their turn into my kind of told stories, you know, about their experiences
that, uh, that are in your state. And, um, minus this was particularly funny because, uh,
when, uh, when they were applying to the national fraternity, they had the list, the achievements and,
uh, attributes and, uh, uh, of all the potential members. And, uh, they wanted to have, you know,
some athletic experiences for everybody, you know, and he played this. He did that. Linus had no
athlete, you know, background, whatever. So my dad was assigned the chore of teaching him to, uh,
lung herders. So they did claim he was a track man. And Linus described, you know, and there's
a very funny way is he and my dad bounding around the track, you know, uh, drill us, jumping over
herders. So he could claim to be a herdler. So he had a Linus that a good sense of humor.
And he told some interesting stories. He told about, uh, he talked for about 45 minutes,
just unscripted. And I just, I'd give anything you had, uh, a recording of that because he talked
about his, uh, his experiences with, uh, uh, passports and pieces. And he was on his way to, uh,
uh, uh, Stockholm to get one of his Nobel Prizes. And they landed in Oslo and nobody met him.
Nobody from the embassy came to greet the point or anything. Uh, he was, you know,
not in good reputed the time. And so he went on to Stockholm on his own. And, uh, then he, uh,
he was also given the, uh, what was the prize he got from, uh, the award he got from Russia,
the Linus piece price, the Linus piece price. Okay. And so he had been awarded the Linus piece
price. And was, you know, requested to go to Russia. And we see even he couldn't get a piece of it.
And he just couldn't get permission from Russia to enter Russia. Here he is going to get the
piece price. They wouldn't let him in the country. So he contacted one of his science colleagues
in Russia and said, you know, what's going on here? Welcome, I can't come. They won't let me come.
So the guy said, I'll look into it and he got back and he said, well, they got two Linus
Pauling files. You know, one is Linus Pauling, you know, piece loving advocate, uh, the world piece.
And so on the other is Linus Pauling, capitalist running dog. And this, when, somehow, the application
got in the comments and cameras running dog file. So they wouldn't grant it. They got a straight
down. But I thought that was, you know, it's kind of a typical cold war snap. There were,
they weren't on the same page anymore. The rest of us were. So anyway, he got there and got the
Linus prize. And of course, this was a controversial event. You know, what's, when was that?
60s. Yeah, 60s, oh, 70s, many. Yeah, cold war. And that didn't go down well. And because he was
being criticized for, you know, his nuclear test ban proposals and atmospheric testing so on. So he was,
he was controversial enough that it was. And I was student at the U of O was a graduate student
later. He came through on some kind of a speaking thing. And it was controversial. So the man was
the 60s, the 50s, the 50s. And, in fact, he was a little aside story that's kind of interesting,
you know, in our life of Trinity, there was a picture of Linus hanging in the Dan. And, you know,
other dignitaries. And this would have been in the early 50s. And his picture was taken down by some
of the members and hidden away somewhere. It's disappeared because of this, you know, the attack from
the right. Yeah, I don't think it faced Linus at all. I think he just plowed on through, you know,
I don't know. So he, you know, he knew we wanted to do. He did his, you know, everlasting credit.
And he and your dad maintained a connection over the years. But he and your dad maintained a connection.
Not a loose, loose connection. I don't think it was ever, you know, there was a history there early days,
which, you know, you don't, you remember those things. But I don't think there was much, you know,
correspondence or much contact. There's he was, you know, operating an entirely different,
different level. Yeah. Well, back to your dad in the early days in Corvallus,
he coached freshman tractor four years, too. I think that's right. I don't have all of that,
some of those information I gave you. I think that was probably his first coaching job was,
was track. Did he maintain an interest in track over the years? Yes, he did. Yeah, he, uh,
he rode your e-load, helping with track leads and helping put them on high school track leads.
So he was, yeah, that was his really first athletic, well, I think. He's also, uh,
outstanding golfer. Yeah. We became the head baseball coach there in the 1920s,
but it was a different situation back then than it is now. How do you mean? Well, he's essentially
a volunteer job for one. Oh, right, right, right. I'm not sure it was a big job. I think he often
all often said that it was not, he was paid, you know, to be an administrator, teacher,
and the physical education department, and academic appointment there. So baseball was just sort of
an aside. It wasn't a very, uh, I don't think, high powered program. There's photos in this thing,
is show the baseball field in 1920. There isn't even a backstop. You know, world of all is there
in the CDA building and the heating plant with a big chimney in all that, but nothing else is around
there. So it was very, you know, low-key operation. And, uh, he, uh, he didn't want to be paid
for it, largely because he said that, uh, didn't there be an expectation? You know,
didn't want that. He wanted to be able to do this as a, as a, as a hobby, you know, as a fun
thing. And it was, and, uh, cutting a lot of notoriety, you know, made a lot of friends,
the lot of fun for him. But he didn't want the, they eventually didn't start paying him, you know,
years later, but it was not a big amount of money. That wasn't his job, that wasn't how he made
it. And I, I was not that kind of shrewd, you know, coaches get fired because they don't perform.
And, uh, he didn't want that, you know, get, find somebody, if you get somebody, if the price
you're getting me for, go for it. But he didn't coach not to stop from 1922 on, he ever has several
periods there. When he was had other administrative, uh, do these in the 30s slash field coach,
I think, for about six years. Yeah, that was fascinating. It just got very,
slidescale, also baseball. Yeah. Yeah. But it was a very low key sport, uh, like I said, 20 games,
maybe it's under, because they were lucky. And they just play local teams. Was there any
recruiting at all? Or I don't know. Or my dad recruited even recruit local and scout around high
school kids in the summer. So nothing like, nothing like today's light years. You know,
you know, there are any scholarships to offer back there. Uh, I think, by the time I got there in the
50s, I think there were some, there were some scholarships. They'd have a handful,
let's split it up in a little piece, as most I think there, you had to work for them in those days.
If you were getting a stipend ride, they called it years, you had to put in a certain amount of hours,
you know, cutting grass or doing something. And, you know, they made us the, we had to do that.
Well, tell me about how his, his coaching career evolved over time. I mean, baseball became
more formal and he became more established and the program became more established. Well,
it was just an evolution. I don't know if they, uh, they were long time rivalries or some great
pictures of one of those pictures in their book Bailey kicking the bucket, you know, in the water
spring out. And so they were around Oregon. They were, you know, lots of good rivalries there.
And, uh, people like the game, uh, but it just developed and got, you know, they're making
the, they were the division was there. And then eventually in the 50s, late 40s, they formed a,
it was the Southern division, the California schools, right, they were, we didn't play them.
And then in that year, they started to play postseason games. And the college were real
series came along by 1946 to 1947, something like that. Stores W Bush was captain of the first
Harvard team. I think they won the college world series. He was the first baseball, George H.
W Bush, first Bush. He's W, yeah, not W, he's W. So, uh, college baseball got a big shot in the
arm when that national competition started. And, um, they did have good years in bed.
Like, uh, it was a, a lot of fun. At any point, did he feel like that he was baseball coach
was his job and, and the other job was less of his job or, you know, I don't think so. He always
pay attention to where you're, who signs the check. And, uh, but baseball was what, uh, you know,
got it as reputation and then as a social thing. And, uh, you know, his players loved him. And,
everybody knew who he was. And, uh, he's very personal guy. And, that people responded to him
and liked him. And, uh, so that makes life easy. Yeah. It's only more about his personality. You see,
he was an intense competitor. He said, oh, yes, yes, yes, yes. He just, on the bench, he was just
a constant motion, you know, throwing grass in the air and stouting up and down and attacking the
unplayers and challenging calls. You don't see that anymore at all. You know, but all the coaches used
to do it. In fact, you know, in the 40s and 50s and 60s. And, uh, uh, but after the game was over,
it'll probably use, you know, everything was fine. But, I think, I think that was, uh, I thought
that was kind of a mega, even your coaches just constantly, you know, spinning out of control,
practically, and your sports remain calm. And, you know, we need to control. But, uh, you know,
his, his intensity was infectious. No question about it. You know, you want to win too.
Well, uh, obviously, Coral's is in a rainy place and, and baseball is played during the
spring when it's often raining. But, did you never, did you have a facilities component to
his job, too? I'm sorry. I'm sorry. I'm still taking care of the field, you know, obviously.
Well, that's, yeah, the players did most of that, because they were on a scholarship arrived,
and then we did a lot of that. So you can imagine what kind of shape that baseball feels in.
We used the armory for our spring, you know, workouts and things. And the season didn't start.
We didn't play any games until the start of spring quarter. Now, it's, you know, they played
what, 60 or 70 games a year now. Yeah. And we were lucky if we played 25 or 30. And that was
fine with me. It's good to get the season over. Go on and do other things. Well, let's travel
like back then. No buses, cars. We took my senior year, I guess, the ones we took our first
out of state trip, spring break. There's a week in there. And so my dad is scheduled as several
games in California. So we piled in these cars and took off. California played Stanford,
Cal, Sacramento, Fresno, and you know, and we didn't have any budget at all. This was the first
out of state trip, you know, the set for the conference play. The first, you know, they do this routinely.
Now they go all over the country, you know, playing in tournaments. And this was interesting experience.
I think it would have been 1953 probably. And we'd pull into some town like, uh, a whole
Berkeley, we're going to play Cal. And my dad is, say, okay, the game, we have the field tomorrow at noon,
games at two thirty or something. Be there noon, see you. We're, we're on our own.
We didn't have a hotel. We didn't have anything. We, I think we had some meal money. I think
you might have given us some meal money. But, um, and we were supposed to fan for ourselves. We did
by staying at fraternities. You know, you know, I phone and call it the U House and say, you know,
I'm down here with the, or you state baseball team, and we come in camp there for a couple of days.
Oh, sure. And also with the guys that weren't in fraternities, we just bring them along, you know,
pretend like they were. So that's how we got by in Fresno, we finally stayed in the hotel
because I think he wanted to know where everybody was when they came time to go home. But other
than that, we were just, uh, just freelancing it. Yeah. That's when I prepared that the day that
everything, but they're private jet, you know. How did the, how did the colon feel itself? It wasn't
call coming to fill them and how did that happen to change over time? Well, I think you just got
just to fill into the usage, you know, uh, uh, before it was dedicated, you know, formally dedicated.
Yeah. Uh, just, did he have to raise some funds? Do you do recall to have an
group in Spain? Or, I don't recall anything like that. I think it was just, uh, based on what the,
what the athletic department would provide. Actually, they put a back step up. They put a back
step up. We had seats, bleachers, and all that kind of thing. But it was, uh, it was pretty primitive.
There were no fans out in the outfield. Oh, really? No. And, uh, and the ground was hard.
And, uh, while we got past the outfielders, it was all run. But you couldn't hit one out of the park.
They were all inside the park. Yeah. So that was a, made an interesting, you know,
addition to the, to the chaplain. So you wanted fast outfielders. You mentioned that training was
pretty casual. Yeah. Yeah. They're what really wasn't any. You know, we'd start to we'd work out
of the job or the armory and I'd have stressed running because that was especially for pictures
because that was, you know, good for you. But, uh, no, you know, half the team probably spoke to
including my dad. And, uh, that was just, you know, we'd take smoke breaks during the game, under the
stands. The buses, things like that. So a little more casual. Yeah. And this is both teams with
a joint for the smoke break. Right. Well, yeah. Yes. I couldn't, I hadn't thought of that. But, uh,
we were on the first base side in those days. Now they're on the third base side. And, uh,
down above Southam, in the field, they wouldn't put ball stadium stands and went around there.
I don't know if you fell for it. Yeah. Yeah. They'll feel nervous. We could down under there.
I understand some, you know, be out of it. Yeah. So it was a, was this, was a schedule before the game
or was there some signal when up there? It was time for a smoke break. I thought about what was just,
let's go. In between yet, you know. Well, his most successful team was probably
1952, the team that won the PCC championship and said he wasn't regional, much of the calls for
old series in Omaha. You were, you were a member of the squad anyway. Right. I was a member of
the squad. It was actually Jay, I was JV, and then you didn't play, uh, you know, a play against
the varsity and with them and practice, in practice or something like that. But, no, I didn't,
I didn't actually, uh, play with the team. And the numbers, they took back to Omaha. I think they were
restricted. So again, it was a fairly small squad. There were players that played, you know,
the longest part of the season that didn't, uh, didn't go back. They got hammered. They lost
the first two games. It was hot. They got there. That wasn't anything. They didn't make it back
for another, well, at 30 years or 35 years or something like that. Well, do you remember much about
that that season? I mean, it sounds like it was sort of a magical season. Well, things came
together and it's a really good athlete. Uh, those days, uh, it was, uh, very common for,
if you guys to play more than one sport. And, uh, let me see, uh, catcher was a, uh, starting
in and put won't in. First basement was a starting forward. Second basement was a starting
guard, the basketball team. Third basement was a linebacker, football linebacker. Left fielder
was another tight end. And so I think out of, if you took away the pitches, I think there were three
starters on that team that didn't start for some other team. So without those guys, we would
help us, you know. So yeah, you could play, and they loved it. They loved baseball because I
got them out of spring football and that sort of thing. So they all wanted to play baseball.
It was a fun sport. What do you remember hearing about the, uh, that Omaha trip? Obviously didn't
go all in the field, but it was, well, I think they went by train long training the very hot
while they were there, Omaha, you know, in that time of year, it'd be pretty, uh, pretty bad,
and I don't think there are accommodations were very good. I think it was only about the,
if you've fifth or sixth year of the College World Series, so I don't think they really got in there
rhythm down yet. And, uh, they, I remember them talking about the heat they couldn't sleep,
and we had these heavy wool uniforms, just one uniform. You know, you want something warm,
you played out here, but back there, it just totally, you know, inappropriate. I think that hurt them.
You remember it being a big deal that made the World Series on campus? Oh, yeah. Yeah, we played, uh,
we played USC, uh, Southern Cal, we were the perennial champions, and we played them in,
in played them in Kerala. So we played them in Los Angeles the year before they beat us down there.
We got them again in Kerala, so 52. And I think we had 5,000 people there. They would
stand up, you know, dragged them in from all over, you know, huge crowd. He was a big deal.
Yeah, that must have been something else. Yeah, it was. It was a great fight.
A couple of, no more early players that I came across, maybe you can comment on, do you know
what you know, Wes Schomerick? Yeah, I knew Wes, um, he was, uh, lived over in the coast.
I think, uh, over on the Nesthucca, and it was a fishing guide and an outdoor type of guy.
And he'd come to all the games, big, early, you know, moisture, you know, guy. And, uh,
it was also a great football player. I don't know if he played in the pros or not, but he was,
he did play pro-based, but he's played major league baseball for the Phillies.
And the other day, I came across as Ed Coleman. It was the right, yeah, his half brother.
He was several years younger and played for me when you stayed. And really good career in the
majors, he played, uh, five or six years. And, uh, they played for the board of the beavers after that.
He was, uh, he had a good career. He's in, uh, he was in the record books for a while. He was a
great-pinch hitter, Helmut, American League, Pinch hit, season, single season, Pinch hit record
for about 30 years or something. So, he had a good success.
Affleck family. Yeah. Yeah.
Did you not have a particular style as a coach and any sort of philosophy of baseball? I mean,
we at KC is famous for a small ball approach. Was there anything like that?
Uh, just beat the other guys up, you know, that 52 team wasn't good. He was the guy for huge,
you know, the starting four were just six five and the football players were six three, six four
for the day and these guys were huge. It's a big picture, isn't everything, physically.
And we would make sure that when we take batting practice before a game, that was always
pretty game rituals, these team would take batting practice, you'd watch the other team.
You know, yeah. And we make sure that the bigger the guys were the earlier they got out.
And yeah, so we brought these great big guys out. And they'd be in the ball all over the place.
And it was intimidating, you know. So yeah, he liked that kind of team.
So he didn't, we didn't play much small ball. I think the idea was just to, you know,
overpower. Yeah, who were some of your dad's best friends in Correlas?
Well, he was there for a very long time, as you said, he's a popular guy.
The early dawn, all the clubs, the young's club, and the older he's well,
and you know, there was a club he joined it. And most of the close friends we had,
there were a lot of them at the department, the lanterns,
the Dixon's, other coaches, the last deal, you know, we just,
lie, stinder the role of close friends, the coaches. And he had close friends just among the
townspeople. He was a small townboy, and liked small town associations.
What was your impression of Slatskyl?
Terrific guy. I liked Slatskyl. I used to caddy for him, and he'd always give me two bucks.
I think that was, so, and he had trick kids who were a little younger than me, but,
of course, I knew them and everything. Slatskyl was a really good guy. He just, you know,
found his niche and stayed in a, just, you know, a good grade. They'd be on, they'd be, you know,
standard participants in the annual beach trips, and the parties, and how they're fishing,
and they, they did all this stuff, you know, all the coaches, and people did all these things together.
No, Slatskyl was a, you know, really, really a good guy.
Trying to think there was something I was going to say about him like him or what it was.
Oh, maybe a little anecdote you may not know. UCLA was looking for a basketball coach,
and the ended up hiring John Wood, but Slatskyl could down. It's teams of beaten them,
UCLA, two years in a row, and the championship. So, he'd be decided to encounter us,
I don't think they could offer him any kind of money, but he used to decided to stay on,
he grew up in Salem, so he was a young, very much a local, local way. So, Wood and Wood,
on to become, you know, a legend. And Slats preferred the smaller arena.
How about long-standing, you know, they know? Oh, yeah. Yeah,
a lot of he was just a really nice guy. He was lots of fun, and then we'd go hunting and fishing, you know,
my dad, and he just, he liked, you know, when you're a kid, you know, when there's people
growing up, so like you, and others, they're just kind of going to the motions, you know?
And a lot of you really like to like to people like kids. This is the terrific guy.
Well, it sounds like outdoors, we're important to this group of men.
Were there other hangouts that they frequented, besides the lodges?
Well, Elf's Club, primarily that was the place where everybody gathered.
It was right in the center of town at the time.
They know if the building is still there, but it was right, you know, on third street or fourth street,
and then, so this was just the focus for all, you know, social activities in town,
get moose and others, but the Elf's Club was the one that most people, you know, frequented.
My sense of the athletic department doing your dad's time is of a pretty tight net group
because that accurate, you think? Yeah, I think so. Yeah. Paul the Monday,
course he came in in late 30s, played basketball, and the Navy, and then came back and never left.
He still went right back, isn't he? He was the JD baseball coach, was he not?
He was, he was the freshman, he was the only assistant. My dad had, and I don't think he got paid,
but he was the tennis coach, assistant basketball coach, and assistant baseball coach.
So he was your coach as a Navy. Right. Well, as he liked, as a coach, who could guy, you know,
baseball hadn't been his game, but the matter, you know, he can manage it.
Never replayed a game against the, uh, as a freshman, they had freshman teams in those days.
He had only played three years of varsity, so he played your first year as a freshman.
And we let overplayed the penitentiary. You know, in Salem, they played a whole thing.
The saying was that they played a strictly home schedule. So we were in there, and it was fun.
You know, the Lettison, I'd never been the penitentiary, and, you know, the field was out in the corner,
was huge wall. And the umpire was, uh, I was pitching the game, actually. And the umpire was,
you know, the convict, and so on. And they were just on each other, totally, they bothered us, you know,
but they were just raising each other, everybody had a nickname. And so it was a, it was a fun experience.
I don't know what the baseball, but I don't know if the prison grays, I don't know if they still have a baseball team or not.
We did have was also an official, you've fished it football and basketball. Yes.
Yeah, and that was his, there was a hobby. I mean, he made money at it. And uh, yeah, a quite a good reputation.
He was a football official with several rose balls. And yes, that's where he finally got out of that
the late 30s. He was two more, two physically demanding, you know, football and the basketball.
No, he did a lot of many was, uh, kind of commissioner for referees, for a while, for the conference.
You would evaluate officials and read them and, you know, with some thanks over year.
Well, he retired in 1966, and he mentioned he was a good golfer at,
he seems to have turned his attention to golf, though. Well, he always played golf.
I'll take that back. He's, I don't know, when he started playing golf, but he helped lay out
the Dallas Country Club. Really. And it was really good and coached to your taught golf.
He never coached golf. He taught golf for years in a physical education department or in state.
And uh, played a lot and was good. Anything like that came easy to it, you know, when you're
athletic, it tends to generalize, you know, all areas. And uh, do you play golf?
A little bit. Do you know what a shank is? Yeah. Well, he developed the shanks,
a terminal occasion of the shanks. And uh, he, uh, didn't play for about 15 years.
Just walked away from the game totally. He was a regular golfer, you know, a couple times a week,
kind of thing. And took the lessons and tried everything. And uh, this couldn't get over it.
And then when you retired, he kind of got back in the golf a little bit. When you retired,
they left Corvalis, my mother, and sold their house and moved to Woodburn, the singer states.
And he was hired there as the golf to take a little golf program. So yeah, that was his retirement
venue. Yeah, golf was important to him. He liked that game.
Again, he was so competitive that it kind of, you know, you can't be overly going to be.
You can't try too hard, you know, and go off as a game. You have to play below your,
you know, your maximum effort. Yeah. And so I think that that was, uh, kind of, uh, made it harder.
Do you know anything more about the, the laying out of the country club? I mean, just didn't
that story. Uh, only that, uh, they planted the all those, uh, they planted fur trees.
They out the course. I remember it was with the members and the volunteer, the volunteer,
and they planted all those fur trees in the rough. And it was only nine holes, you know,
begin with, and very yellowy and clay, and it's just like concrete, you know, to play it. So,
we know that was laid out in, uh, during mid-20s. So, he was a charter member then. I think probably
what it's, yeah, probably pretty close. Um, well, Colin Field was dedicated as such in April 1981.
I'm sure that meant something to him. Do you have memories of that particular moment of that event?
Yeah, my, uh, older son and I went down, and, uh, and we're there. There's pictures and, uh,
and documentation, uh, you know, in the material that was there. And, uh, Robert McBicker was a president.
Jack Riley was the coach, and it was during, I think it was secondary to a game. I can't remember exactly.
I think it was. Very nice event. And then they didn't meet a speech. He was a very good presenter.
And, uh, the tell jokes. He was, you know, just, there's, I think, uh, I don't think it's a record of what
he said at that event, but there's some other information that there's some, he would write it out ahead of time.
So there's some things in there that he said, but he could, uh, he was good. Good on his feet.
Do you think I meant a lot to him that the, the field had been named after him, officially?
Oh, I think so. We have, we wouldn't, you know, and that was, uh, that was a source of pride,
but you're a nice honor for him. And, uh, after that, it sounds like he got another job in baseball,
the Portland Marle. He familiar with the history of the Portland Marle. Okay.
Well, he, uh, the Bing Russell, who is a actor, Western actor, the Portland Beaver franchise,
and then kind of left bacon, he picked this up for, for actually nothing. I think it was
partly to provide a venue for Kurt, who is some Kurt Russell to play, who is quite an acting baseball player.
And the Mavericks were independent, the own team. They weren't owned by any other, major league team or anything like that.
And these were just free agents, some pros, some amateurs, and, uh, Bing Russell hired somebody to
manage the team, and he would be around with these players up. And they played, and he, uh, it wasn't
AAA, it was, uh, maybe a AA level down the moment we'll see. And, uh, I think there's a movie being
made about, you know, being books for things like that. And, uh, they were a very flamboyant, you know,
bunch, and, uh, and, uh, when, at one point, Frank Peters, then he, he did. Okay, he was in Oregon State,
baseball player, basketball player played on that final four, basketball team. And it played
professional baseball, and he was hired as the manager. And, uh, he hired my dad to be his third
base coach. He played for my dad. And so, uh, there's a Mavericks hat around the house somewhere,
so he spent two or three seasons, you know, helping, you know, manage the board of Mavericks.
That was later on with pretty late in his life. Right. Yeah. Okay, so let's turn the attention to you now.
Um, you were born and raised in Corvals, and interested in knowing the Corvals that you knew
the Grand Rapids, a boy, small town all the way. Everything just revolved around the campus.
Summer time, everything just quit. Everybody just tended their yards and lay around, uh, you know,
they didn't have much in the way of summer school. Oh, uh, they did have a summer school. One of my
dad's, uh, assignments was to work with the summer students and setting up, uh, to field trips.
They go to, you know, uh, the bodybuild dam and Timberline Mods and all the coast and he organized.
He just loved this kind of thing, you know. And so, but it was, uh, it was nice place to be in the summer.
Everybody was going on and, uh, the Corvals calendar was Oregon State's calendar, you know,
New Year's Day was when school started in the fall. You know, like wasn't in, wasn't in January.
Because everything just focused on the activities on campus and, uh, most everybody, you know,
worked for the Kent College. One, you know, directly you're indirectly, uh, wasn't an excuse for
girl. I wasn't being there, but I had been for Oregon State. So, and it was, uh,
it was, uh, it was a very nice, uh, place to grow up. Campus was our playground, uh, uh, uh,
the kids, you know, we just, you know, how to get into every building and, uh, in the
be saying, you know, we needed to get into, uh, uh, uh, uh, our parents didn't know what we were doing.
I don't think they wanted that what we were doing. So it was a, it was a, it was a playground.
As you got a little bit older, and to say, the high school age,
we're, we're going to the places that the kids congregated. You mean, Jim Caballas? Yeah.
Well, there was some, there was some, uh, there was some drive-ins,
and there was a drive-in theater, uh, between Aubrey and Caballas,
that was a fun place to be. There were places outtown, uh, restaurants. I don't remember
having any particular, it was kind of like, uh, American graffiti. Did you ever see
American graffiti? And there was a lot like, Caballas was a lot like the American
graffiti, uh, you know, on the odds. Very nice place to grow up.
Everybody kind of had their, their, their, uh, activities, you know, everybody guard
mothers all collected antiques and played bridge, and most of the mothers didn't work,
faculty wives, they weren't jobs. First of all, it wasn't, uh,
I don't think it was considered a, uh, quite as socially acceptable for mothers to be working.
It wasn't kind of an admission that you needed the money, you know what I mean?
So, there really had lots of time, there wasn't much, there weren't very many organized
activities, you know, we kids, we just did what we wanted to do,
if they were the home for dinner, you know, when that was it. So, what sort of impact do you,
do you remember the depression having on the town? It sounds like the, the faculty refer
to the, you know, the economic impact. But, well, that was my impression, you know, I didn't,
I wasn't the hardly aware of the depression, uh, it was just the way things were. I was born in
1931, of course, that's just when it, uh, was, uh, in its worst. And, uh, it didn't affect the,
the university, you can't always let that match, everybody, uh, I don't think they had much
the way it cutbacks. I think, although I can't, I couldn't document it, there were times when
they did not get paid at all, but the state they were given, I'll use, and I think they were honored
later on. But, uh, that was, it was, uh, it kept me thin. And, of course, there were migrants in
Krabalus and, uh, show up at our back door and want food and that sort of thing. So,
it was, it was there. And, uh, of course, World War II came along and ended that, and I heard,
well, that's my next question is, well, how did this, how did the town respond to World War II?
What was it like during that period? It's like, well, of course, there were no men around.
They had, uh, a, uh, ASTP programs and anything to it. It was an Army sponsored program for soldiers
to go to college. Then I think they became officers at the end of it. So, there's an ASTP program,
but these are soldiers, essentially, assigned to that role. And, as far as men went on campus, that was
about, yeah, the women lived in the fraternity houses and, uh, uh, uh, but the school kept going,
but, uh, you know, the war was having a big impact on it. Was it there in the midst of its
Yes, it was nice. Yes, uh, camped air was had a huge impact on prevallus and Albany.
And, uh, it, uh, you know, it was a, it was a, it was a, it was a basic, well, you know, of camped air.
It was a, for basic infantry, infantry, basic training. I think they put forward divisions,
infantry divisions through their three or four years, it was right. And that's a lot of soldiers.
We had, we had one living in our house. We always had one living in our house with us,
and I put that back. So, we didn't have soldiers living there. We had his wife living there.
In our spare bedroom, and this was pretty typical. The wives would follow the soldiers out
to be around in their basic training. And these guys get released from, you know, camped air
for weekend or something, and here, and caught up the stairs at night. You know, the GI boots
and down the next morning. And so, uh, so that was pretty standard, too. So, the city was, you know,
supporting that effort. My mother was a great lady, and this kind of a nurses auxiliary
volunteer that a hospital that camped air. And, uh, they were, uh, uniforms. They worked in the military,
anything, but they would write letters for soldiers and, uh, keep them company in the hospital,
unless, and so she did that during the whole war. This is a volunteer. We were able to go out
here there, and all of us at off limits. I don't remember going on the base during the war,
afterwards I did, once the war was over. Why didn't I take that back? We did go out there, because
we were in the gym doing something. Oh, I know, yeah, my dad had, uh, during what they construction
of it, they had a baseball league. Her saltball wanted to have my dad coached one of those teams,
the construction teams. And, uh, so I was on the camped air a couple of times. And one time we were in
the gym, I guess it would be, and there was a whole slug of, uh, few W's in there. We were
storing few W's in the camped air during the war, and these were, uh, African corps,
guys, Germans, and by they were tough looking bunch. And then there were also Italians around,
and they were, so, you know, they were more open than friendly and stuff. So they were being housed there.
I don't know if they ever were escaped or not, but they didn't look like the security was retired.
They had it pretty well. Pretty good as it was. That's interesting. I had none about that.
They expansive it there. It's amazing when you see it now. The expansive it there was,
it was amazing when you see it now. It's quite, and it's, there's not a lot there. It was,
it must be the second biggest, uh, in Oregon. No, it was huge. Uh, covered maps about that in our
range. The camped air, you eat a lot of the greets for an artillery range, and we could
hear moving away from the war. You mentioned in your memoir that the family traveled to San Francisco
for the world's fair in 1939. Oh, yeah. Do you remember that at all? Oh, yeah. That was, uh,
green out in me, and we stayed with my green aunt lived in San Francisco.
And, uh, yeah, that was a nice, nice event. It takes your time of a lot of other facts from that.
Um, well, tell me about high school at Coral's high school. You're the senior class president.
I want to indeed, uh, and, uh, had a lot of fun in high school. You know,
I did a lot of people don't have good experiences in high school, but I had good experiences.
You know, everything wasn't 100%, but, you know, I was on the baseball team and the golf team.
And, uh, you know, had good friends and had a nice time. Uh, we won the state high school
basketball championship. I was a junior. I wasn't on the team, but that was,
doesn't get any better than that when you're in the high school, you know, to have the
win the state basketball championship. We meant the decision to go to Oregon State College.
It sounds like there was, there wasn't much of a decision. I mean, there was no, that was kind of data.
That was, you know, I don't, I can't think of anybody in my class high school graduate class
that did go anywhere else. You know, initially. And, uh, there were a lot of faculty kids
throughout Wisconsin. Obviously, so they were going to go to college, but that was the
closest one and the most affordable. So that's kind of where we all ended up. Yeah.
What was it like playing in your dad's baseball program? Fine. You'd get a good time.
Have a great time. And, uh, it was, uh, you know, no stress. Everybody accepted it and, uh,
had a good time. Yeah. That seems to be, it was a real honor, you know, for me.
You played center baseball. Yeah. That's what everybody did in those days.
There was on the baseball team because, uh, you know, my dad and one, we want to be playing.
And he won, you know, his players did playing too. And, uh, we'd be hired. We'd be sent out
to these small towns every town had a baseball team, a semi-pro baseball team, which means
semi-pro means professionals, ex-professionals could play on the team.
Back in those days, that it was a no-no in terms of, uh, amateur status,
who are supposed to play with pros, with the main exception for baseball. So,
these town teams that have some ex-pros and some college guys and some locals. And, uh,
he was a big deal for the town and they could get his jobs, you know,
we're going to the woods or pulling on the green chain or something like that.
And that was about what was out there and the mill pond job. I was not, that was not a,
I was living in Krivalas as summer and they gave you.
As a summer, we went to, uh, Air Force Base and whatnot. Anyway, uh, that was a mill,
south of Monroe, and, um, had been mill pond. And yeah, that was a,
that was a dangerous job and a tough one. We'll tell some more about what that job until.
Well, uh, every saw mill had a, uh, a mill pond that were, uh, store logs and, uh,
then the logs would be brought up to the, uh, or the, or there was a conveyor belt.
And then we'd be then lifted, uh, convey into the saw mill and cut into the boards.
And, uh, the people that moved the logs around were called pound pond monkeys.
And you're out there in your court boots and you're, we pull them all with.
And, uh, trying to carry out these logs and, uh, you know, pushing across the pond and getting
over to the, where they'd be picked up. And there about five of the same, uh, pond monkeys.
And none of us knew what we were doing. And they dumped the logs and one end of the pond of log trucks.
And then we gathered up five or six of these, or eight of them, wrapped and propelled across the,
across the pond. And then, uh, they lived at, there were a couple of, uh, professional pond monkeys there.
And they were just split around, you know, flying across the logs and we were in the water half the time.
Interesting experience. And this terrible water, you know, with, uh, like I said,
but my mother wouldn't let me in the house, you know, they could smell some air.
So that's what we did. That was those, the jobs are available in them wage, no unions, you know,
so you're just totally the mercy of, uh, you know, uh, owner.
But there were guys that was, you know, that was a career for a lot of people.
You know, for us at least, there was just a summer experience.
So it was a great incentive to, uh, believe me, you know, to stay in college and find something better.
Because that's where a lot of these guys were going to spend their lives, you know,
corner of the region and sort of thing. Oh, and that's a much just in characters.
I'm sure. Yeah. And then that was spent summers in co-keel and brookings.
Doing that sorts of jobs. Played for their town team.
Some rough and humble towns. They were, they were indeed.
Cowboys, Indians, and fishermen,
loggers, you know, he spent a summer in primal too.
Right, primal. Yeah, co-keel, brookings, and primal, those are my three stars.
Well, you know, that dealt with Slon too. I was, yeah, I was a legacy and, uh, looked at other houses,
but they had a nice combination. I thought, uh, athletes and scholars and
wee schools, you know, didn't take themselves too seriously.
They were, you know, a good bunch of guys. And, uh, so I never had any regrets about that.
That worked out pretty well. Nice, nice group.
Um, you mentioned that, if I take out a fraternity,
I don't know if prank is the right word for it, but there's a story
involving skim race beauty in Oregon. Yeah, you used to Oregon. No, they had a, we had a
genius for, you're coming up with stuff like that. No, that's a true story.
And, uh, when I was a freshman, my freshman class, I didn't have to go on that, but they
went down and we looked piece of it off, they didn't get the whole thing. But they did
dynamite some of it off, you know, the skimmers do. Never had caught me to back.
And, uh, two years later, went back and really, you know, got the whole thing this time.
And it was, uh, it, uh, they also got the way with that, you know, the FBI was
interviewing everybody on campus, and I'll try to get a handle on who is dynamite was considered
a, you know, but the age of substance, and they steal it from the stump, the last in class,
or you're standing there with an egg school, and sometimes the class. So these guys
steal dynamite, the caps, nutty, you know, just nutty. But, uh, they never caught out,
he did it. Uh, and this is the big, oh, there's a big, oh, and it's a big concrete, oh.
And then, then the, uh, the guys that didn't went back later, and they'd gather up pieces,
chunks of it, and everybody had, and the house had a chunk of this, oh, when they're going
to get the other desk. The paint, I don't know, it was about that thick, you know,
it'd been painted, so the, you're, back in the comma days, you know, where you stay,
would be down in a painted orange, and then, where I get to get up the next day,
and paint yellow, so that would happen a lot, but I, I think that was the last time
but it would've, uh, it'd've got the whole lot. Last time. I don't remember if you,
you know, interesting size, or I was not as a game in lots in one time years, years later,
And, and I was relating this story, you know, but my fraternity being, you know, I
mean dynamite of the old, scared of the guy behind me, he says, came around, he says, is that
a true story?
And he said, you know, you read the guys, I didn't that, and I said, yeah, he said, I wrote
my master's thesis on that, on the dynamite of the old, so it was a story that, you know,
I had legs at least.
Well, what was social like like for you in school?
Rich?
No.
Very good.
Where you stayed was a nice friendly place, and there were too many men and not enough women,
you know, student body was mostly, you know, a high school, injury school, and all
of that.
So, men out and over the women, but it was good.
We had a lot of fun.
It was, if you lived on campus, which most of us did, we lived in our fraternity.
You were in that like a different universe.
You know, your parents were glad to have you out of the house, and you were glad to be out
of the house.
And you might as well be in a Chicago, you know, the amount of interaction that took place
this wasn't any.
Yeah.
What sort of events were important on the social calendar?
All house dances.
You know, I said, one major, every house that had one major house dance, every quarter.
And those were big events.
And, you know, if you were dating somebody, you'd get invited to the her house dance,
and she invited you to invite your yours and so on.
So, there's a lot of that.
And a lot of beer drinking out of Murphy's Beach and Murphy's Beach is.
You know, south of town.
There's a tavern.
We've got about two or three miles out of town on the right-hand side.
And a whole Murphy's.
That's called Murphy's.
Okay.
Well, just past that half a mile, there's a road that goes off to the east.
I went down to the river.
And I think there's, I don't know, what's down there now.
But back then, it was a gravel operation.
And this is where all the part you took place.
This is called a burst beach.
And nothing to do with the tavern.
But that was where everybody gathered.
It's a new one to me.
That's a new one for me.
Oh, yeah.
That was the place.
And, you know, if anybody wanted to do a rest of this,
or a rest of this, or a hospitalist, right?
Everybody knew where we were.
And it wasn't just my fraternity.
Everybody was out there.
You know, the football team, the basketball team, everybody.
You know.
So, a lot of partying going on.
I don't think anything has changed.
I don't think.
We played baseball in the springs.
And the springs in the summer.
Did you do anything in the fall or winter be ready for the season?
Or is it just being a role student?
I think once the season was over, we were done.
I don't remember any particular.
Each season, you know, each football season, basketball season,
baseball season, baseball season.
They had to start to stop time.
And, you know, we have guys that played three sports.
And, uh, throwing a state.
Three major sports.
Started in each year every team.
So, you can do that, then.
And I don't think that's.
Can they do that now?
Thanks, okay.
I think very few do if they could.
Yeah.
Now, how about school?
How about what was your academic experience like?
I was a moderate success, modest success.
I was a business administration.
And that wasn't a very stimulating, you know, major for me.
And, you know, I made my grades.
And, I was only on probation once.
So, that's not too bad for four and a half years.
So, but I graduated.
Any teachers about that made any impact on you?
Pardon?
Any teachers?
You know, Gordon guilty.
Gordon guilty.
He was a good teacher.
I, you know, this is a long time ago.
Can you tell me more about him?
I'm interested in guilty.
Well, Gordon, you know, had, uh, he'd been in Europe during the Second World War.
And had, uh, with some of those people that participated in,
saving the, you know, uncovering the German stations of art and so on.
And, uh, I really made a major contribution there.
And then he was a, also, a woodblock print collector.
And a huge Japanese woodblock print collection.
And taught, of course, clothes.
Serbated visual arts or something.
Anyway, it was a review of, you know, art and history and so on.
Fascinating course.
He taught that every year.
And then, uh, later on, he became,
Dean, I think, of liberal arts to me.
I think so.
Yeah.
And he lived right around the corner of the entire,
or you stayed.
He was a good guy.
Is some was there, some was a photographer.
Yeah.
I'm going to ask you a little bit about the climate on campus during the time you were there.
You were, uh, they're towards the end.
I think the, uh, large influx of GI Bill students.
And you're mentioned in, in your memoir,
they were somewhat belief.
Oh, yeah.
And I'm, I'm guessing that you have a sense of,
of why from your own military experience.
But can you talk a little bit about the GI influence on campus?
Well, it was huge.
You know, uh, first there was a huge number of them.
And then, a lot of them are married.
They're older.
Uh, these guys, you know, they weren't interested in the morning.
Booklets or any of that stuff.
That just went by the boards.
You know, they weren't having any of it.
You know, these wanted to get in there.
Get their education and get on with their lives.
And so that changed the whole campus tender.
You know, totally.
And then here at the Walinkay, my group, you know,
maybe to a high school graduate,
and never, you know, get any, you know,
get any of it on anything.
And they're all the upper, the upper two classes in the
fraternity house were all a little more two guys.
And they ran the, these, they ran these fraternities like,
boot camps.
The, the guy down the hall for me,
one of the seniors.
I think it's a senior there by that timing.
Bob Kyle.
He didn't wounded in the Battle of the Bulge.
You know, he didn't mess around with those guys, you know?
And they didn't take any, you know,
they were very serious and very business-like.
And they were good role models, you know,
we learned from those guys.
So yeah, they changed the whole campus.
Philosophy has turned it upside down.
And then they were, I started in 1949.
So they were kind of a tail end of it.
And once it came along after me,
none of us had ever been in the military.
Some, occasionally, were the Korean War came along,
and that changed a lot of things.
We had a lot of Korean War veterans around that.
So did the Brooklyn tradition die out at that point?
I mean, that was very strong before then.
What's that?
The Brooklyn's, and things like that, that this deceased is,
Yeah.
Yeah, that just sort of, any people tried to get it back in place,
but if I don't think it ever would be,
it wasn't the same as it had been.
And things were changing anyway.
You know, it wasn't just the World War II events.
The whole world had changed.
You know, the Second World War just changed everything.
Whole majors didn't matter anymore.
You know, new technologies coming on.
So the very revolutionary, in retrospect,
in a very revolutionary period.
Yeah.
Well, and you mentioned that some,
I'm trying to ask about the, the subject of race,
and especially the example of the man who you write about in your book.
It was not a revolution on campus by any stretch,
but it's an inkling of a very gradual change.
It was going to come later in terms of the topic of race.
It looks you.
Well, or you say it was a pretty pretty,
one race institution at the time.
We had black students from Africa,
change students, and Asians, of course,
been around for a long time.
So it wasn't totally white, but it was predominantly.
And there were no black athletes.
Oregon had black athletes in the 30s.
Football players, Jackie Robinson's,
who were brother.
Mac was a track man at Oregon.
And so Oregon State was, you know,
late to the game.
And Dave Man was recruited out of California
to come and be Oregon State's first black athlete,
which he was.
And it was a very successful.
And I didn't know him very well personally,
but he was, he stood out on question about it.
And he was, he was not a,
what would you call, he was not a self-refacing person
that a good way to put it.
But not a bad person.
I mean, he didn't cause any problems or anything.
He just, he was new to, you know,
this was a new thing in Oregon State,
and the Corvellus.
Yeah, confident day.
Yeah, very confident.
Good athlete.
Didn't take any stuff, you know.
He wanted campus boxing training.
It was fascinating.
There was a campus boxing training.
Yeah, intermural.
It wasn't well.
It was, yeah, intermural.
And yeah, it just three, three,
three, three roundabouts.
Yeah, he wasn't that.
Was this a period of time where there were many
concert sets on campus?
Still were.
And what was that like, did you have
did you have classes in them or?
You know, I don't remember having.
I think they were mostly used for hot space.
Meeting rooms and things like that.
They weren't big enough ready for a classroom.
So just reflective of a period of expansion.
Can't rest in the influx of new students.
Yeah.
I'll ask you about a couple of things that happened at,
at OSC during your time,
but in 1950, Gil Call Seam opened.
Do you remember, do you remember that?
Well, I don't remember having any major event.
You know, it had been coming for a long time.
It just didn't magically appear.
You know, everybody knew it was coming.
It was, yeah, it wasn't big event.
It was a state of the art at the time.
You know, that was.
The rest dates, that's what it facilities were.
First class, parker.
Field was new.
Oregon had rigging wooden stands.
Still when California schools had big stadiums.
But, you know, Oregon states,
or so was a pretty good spec key.
It was responsible for most of that.
Really?
Yeah.
Do you have recollections of attending basketball games in the old men's gym?
Yes, I did.
So, slides field, teams, knockover, DCOA, twice in a row.
Yeah, I get polled.
It held 2,000 people.
Yeah.
There was about anything around all the way around the men's gym.
And that, you know, the two.
Yeah.
So, yeah.
I started going there when I was probably,
four or five years old.
It must have been quite an environment.
Get what it was.
Just athletics all the way.
How about football at Belle Field?
Well, it was a mud bowl, sort of was.
You know.
And you're close to the field.
But the student section was on the west side.
And in those days, if you can believe it, the COVID's all wore heels and stockings and hats.
Just the game.
Imagine that?
Yeah.
That's amazing.
Well, so we sort of wind up here a little bit.
I'm interested in knowing about your continued association with OSU after you graduated.
Obviously, we had a career in military.
We went on to other things, graduate studies and career.
Well, when I came, I left where you stayed in 1954, spring of 1954, came back in 66 or 67 or something like that.
And I lived in Chicago and Evan Stein, Lincoln Nebraska and Pennsylvania and other places.
You know, the kind of stops you make.
And then it was hired by, or, you know, sciences university recruited by them.
You know, a certain role they were looking for.
And came back.
And my dad had just retired for your state, so there wasn't any of that overlapping.
But he was, of course, very closely involved.
And, you know, he had season tickets, so I just picked up going to the football games.
And, you know, that sort of thing.
But that I wasn't, you know, associating the Oregon State in any direct professional.
Capacity.
But it was still part of our lives.
And then, you know, I was a lifetime member of the life member of the Illinois Association.
The varsity O was kind of kicking you out a little bit.
They were getting things going.
And then the baseball field project came on.
Pat Casey put that together and asked me if I would be on their committee.
And did was, and, you know, the fundraising committee.
And we were successful largely because of the $1 billion grant from the Goss John Goss,
who had sold a piece of property and was going to pay a huge tax bill, so he decided to do something with it.
And that got kicked back started.
And he'd put it in there.
This wasn't, you know, he, I don't know how many years he had been coaching,
but I bet it was close to 10 of the time the stadium project came along.
So, you know, you think of the baseball project.
And I think the whole program is a project.
You know, it's so different from what it was, you know, back in the day.
It's patting, you know, overnight success.
You know, it just came in and winged the magic wander.
They happened.
But that's not the case at all.
He started going to the Brownsville.
And they didn't even charge for baseball games when Jack Wright was there.
And even in Pat's early days, he could just walk in any time, you know, free.
And, but he is a, I think a remarkable person, a remarkable developer.
I think he would have done well whenever he was, you know,
like a very good state that he chose baseball.
But he has, he's a talented person, you know, not your normal,
just your regular everyday coach.
And he spearheaded this, and we meet up here in Portland.
And we, you know, tap people we knew.
And, and there are some major donors that stepped up.
And, uh, they're built.
So that was a huge, that was a real sea change, you know,
the baseball program they have that facility.
It was interesting because prior to that time,
even Jack Riley and Tencelli and others might have done something similar.
But, uh, until...
Can't remember which one of the presidency was.
It was after the bigger public burn.
Could have been.
No, no wasn't.
It was after him, either.
Yes, sir.
All right, sir.
I think it was Paul Richard Wright.
Said it would be OK to build a permanent facility on that location.
But the university's policy prior that time,
I've always been that this was too valuable piece of property.
You know, it is right.
Not the center campus, but it's right on campus.
And they want to put dorms there and things like that.
Well, so they wouldn't permit any kind of improvement in facilities.
Nothing.
Until the visitors said, okay, you can do this.
And then that will put the door for a pat to go out and begin to
and then John Goss coming along.
But those two things came together and made it possible to put a permanent facility on that site.
You know, it's the oldest baseball field in college baseball.
Well, it is the oldest or the second oldest.
I think there might be some dispute about that.
But it's one or the two.
And somebody wanted out their one day in 1907 and drove a stake in the ground.
This will be owned late.
But it's never moved.
You know, it's been a big success.
I think that was a good for Pat, good for the program.
I think it made it possible to recruit.
That's everything at baseball.
And Pat, now with his reputation, he just recruits nationally.
You know, he doesn't recruit.
He just answers phone calls basically.
Stowning success.
You know, somebody said everything went to their one day first college world series.
And I said, what would your dad, what would your dad feel about that?
Yeah, but he'd be proud.
Nice.
And he'd be dumbfounded this way.
Just, you know, considering the facilities of the attitudes and so on.
So he's, he's at a remarkable remarkable job.
Yeah.
Well, the last thing I want to ask you about is just your thoughts on the current direction of the university.
Things have changed my early last few years.
And there's a lot of momentum heading in different directions.
What do you think of all this?
Well, I think or you say it's got a really a lot to be proud of.
I think, you know, the current administration has really been in place long enough.
I think it's been, there's continuity there.
There was some, you know, most of the presidents stay more than four or five years.
It's that, you know, they move on to their things.
So I think that continuity has been important.
And I think they play the funding game very well.
You know, the technology grants and all this sort of thing.
I don't follow it with the microscope.
But I don't think they have the reputation of the deserve.
I think it's not, not read their fault.
Every institution has areas with excellence.
And where you state is certainly no exception.
But it's not the kind of thing that gets the headlines.
So, but no, I think I think it's, it's a really fine institution.
I know, when my older son went there and had a great time.
So, and they just completed a big fundraising campaign.
Yeah, just about a billion dollars.
Billion?
Was that, yeah?
One of the better campaigns around the country, I guess, wouldn't that?
Yeah.
I think so.
So, they do a good job.
I think, let me go against it.
I think it's possible to get a good education there.
I think one of the things that was kind of a negative, when I was there,
they had virtually nothing in the way of liberal arts.
And you could only take two years.
They only offered liberal arts on the, you know, the undergrad or the lower division level.
And that that closed out a lot of, you know, it's an age when you really ought to be looking around
at, you know, other things.
And the opportunities weren't there.
You had to channel yourself into one of these technical oriented majors.
It wasn't always a good fit for everybody.
So, I think the fact that they expanded that, you know, that option is, I think,
adds a lot to it.
I think they really made that, that return the corner for them as far as I was concerned.
I mean, they developed a liberal arts college and you could major in it this long.
Yeah.
Well, Ralph, I want to thank you for this.
It's been very interesting and fun and enlightening for me.
Well, it's been a real pleasure.
Thank you very much.
Okay.
Thank you.